[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler bruno
m'égare ban chef du service réanimation
à l'hôpital lariboisière à paris bonsoir
ou veut nommer herman merci d'être avec
nous à vos côté joëlle mélin députée
européenne est reine bonsoir madame
merci d'être avec nous france 4 boeuf
délégué départemental du modem merci à
vous également le mini zoo la santé donc
un qui évoque cet après midi à leur
semblait une vague longa qui frappe tout
le pays sans distinction avec un taux
d'incidence est levée et le porte-parole
gabriela talent qui mettait en garde
écouter la pression va continuer à
s'accentuer durant les prochaines
semaines et nous devrions dépasser les
3000 patients atteints du coup vide en
réanimation très rapidement et atteindre
les 4000 patients atteints du cosy dans
réanimation tour des fêtes mais alors
c'est pas très brillant 4000 patients au
real je rappelle que c'est à 5000 qu'on
avait expliqué que le système
hospitalier craquer qu'il fallait
confiné aujourd'hui bruno m'égare banon
n'ait quasiment tous vaccinés c'est
quand même un petit peu la douche froide
qu'est ce qui se passe
mais écoutez comme vous le savez il y à
peu près 6 mignan de france et non
vaccinées dont un million de personnes
âgées avec des comorbidités
malheureusement le virus donc le variant
d'état circule un niveau extrêmement
élevé donc le risque d'être contaminé
est important et malheureusement ces
personnes on prenne un risque en étant
contaminée de développer une fois me
grave de la maladie et donc de devoir
être hospitalisée y compris d'aller en
réanimation y compris malheureusement eu
de décéder malgré tout les traitements
qu'on peut offrir à l'hôpital le fait
évidemment la vaccination on le sait
aujourd'hui
protège parfaitement contre le risque de
faire une forme grave de la maladie et
donc évidemment où je renouvelle l'appel
que les autorités sanitaires ont déjà
lancé à la vaccination de tous les
adultes et bien sûr surtout les
personnes à haut risque de faire une
foire au gras sachant évidemment que à
partir de la vaccination il faut
attendre un mois et demi pour avoir
protection nécessaire
or le problème c'est que ces personnes
qui
malheureusement parce qu'elles ont reçu
une mauvaise information ne croyant pas
à l'intérêt de la vaccination
adoptent le mode de vie des personnes
vaccinées et donc de fait évidemment
sang contaminé et se retrouve dans
l'animation aujourd'hui 80% des
personnes en réanimation ne sont pas
vaccinés alors sauf que les choses ne
semblent pas vraiment s'arranger le
nouveau variant omicron pourrait devenir
dominants d'ici à mi-février alerte
lancée aujourd'hui par la présidente de
la commission européenne alors quand
dans le même temps l'agencé européenne
prévient que la vaccination seule ne
suffira pas à joëlle mélin ya de quoi
être un petit peu pessimiste avant le
moral dans les chaussettes quand même
oui même sans ces informations on l'a
automatiquement
le fait est qu'il faut reconnaître que
il ya de quoi être déboussolé
surtout si on s'aperçoit que pour la
deuxième année consécutive et si on se
tourne vers les chinois ça fait plus de
deux ans et demi que ce virus hini siens
que le virus initial circulent et que
l'on peut se dire à quoi sert la
vaccination alors moi je serais un petit
peu et auteur j'ai été pour la
vaccination initialement dans quel suivi
toutes les consignes elle eu pour ma
famille proche et moi même au temps
effectivement de se poser un problème
parce qu'on n'est pas dans une véritable
politique vaccinale on est d'abord avec
des thérapies géniques qu'on ne
connaissait pas encore il ya un an au
moins dans leur application et 2 nous
savons très bien que nous vaccinons à
partir d'une souche qui a dix femmes
véritablement de l'initiale a disparu
depuis au moins 18 mois d'ailleurs le
renouvellement au niveau de l'europe les
mains à renouveler certains contrats
avec les laboratoires que dans la mesure
où nous proposons des souches adapté or
la politique vaccinale veut que l'on que
l'on vaccine avec des souches qui ont
été pré déterminée de nombreux mois
avant qu'un débutant sur la chaîne de
production lors n'y est pas du tout il
est évident que ça marche 2 - 1 mondial
s'est tassée déboussolant comme tout le
monde et aussi il ya des tonnes mesure
génie sont pas prises la première c'est
bien entendu ne pas prendre de mesures
abord aux zones d'arrivée du vaccin
stadiers venant des stands ouest c'est
classique mais aussi pour la troisième
fois d'angleterre et de manière massive
on ne prend aucune mesure de protection
frontière jeudi pas de les fermer je
dire les mesures ordinaire aucune dessus
de monsieur bernard megaman on en avait
déjà parlé les mesures d'isolement
automatique des cas avérés en hôtel
qu'ovide il faudra pour niary mieux vaut
même si ces cinquante mille personnes
par jour mieux vaut isolé 50000 c'est à
dire à peu près de cent mille deux cent
cinquante mille personnes par semaine
que tout un pays enfin je dire ça tourne
sous sens et personne ne l'a fait on a
parlé de séquençage est en train on en a
absolument pas travailler sur les
thérapeutiques alternatives il faudra le
faire aussi on en parlera justement
rennes mais nan parce qu'il ya plein air
qui sort une pilule d'ailleurs qui sort
aujourd'hui aux états unis mais restons
justement sur ce variant et sur cette
maxime nation on va voir ce chiffre un
cas communiqué les laboratoires pfizer
by one tech
le vaccin donc vous lisiez en moins
efficaces contre le vario mikron il
protège qu'à 70% contre les casses les
verts vous allez me dire c'est déjà pas
mal mais enfin quand même ça baisse de
20%
clairement france au 4e boeuf pourquoi
on n'attend pas que pfizer sorte une
version modifiée en mars je crois prévu
pour pour mars pour faire cette fameuse
troisième dose à laquelle tout le monde
vous exhorte c'est vrai que les gens n'y
comprennent plus rien
et je crois qu'on n'attend pas parce que
nous sommes à la mi décembre et que si
nous attendons le mois de mars d'avoir
un vaccin qui soit pleinement
opérationnel à supposer qu'ils le soir
il y aura eu quelques clics et quelques
dizaines de milliers de morts d'ici là
donc que le gouvernement par au plus
près et et nous apprenions tout à
l'heure se traite à monter mouvant
évidemment qu'il voudrait des consignes
claires qu'il vaudrait de l'anticipation
qu'il voudrait des mesures générales
mais il n'est pas possible de mettre
tout un pays sous cloche nous le savons
bien il n'y a pas dans notre pays des
obligations vaccinales
donc il faut tenir avec les moyens du
bord et s'adapter au jour le jour je
pense que c'est ce que fait le
gouvernement
j'espère qu'il y aura un efficace dans
quelques mois j'espère je pense que les
vaccins s'adapteront mais il faut aussi
en appeler à la responsabilité de chacun
c'est à dire qu'on soit d'ailleurs
vacciner ou pas s'abstenir d'un exter de
fréquentation sociale d'un excès de fait
d'un excès de peau de fin d'année contre
diverses respecter les gestes barrières
et il n'y a que par la responsabilité
individuelle qu'on arrivera à tenir le
temps qu'il faudra ça commence à faire
beaucoup des restrictions nous demande
beaucoup de sacrifices et nous tous on
va aussi prendre l'exemple d'un
octogénaire aujourd'hui en février
dernier cette personne était convoqué
pour cette première dose suivi de la
deuxième 15 jours après six mois plus
tard je vais dernier donc rappelle avec
la troisième en janvier cette personne
aura un rappel pour une nouvelle dose ça
fera donc si j'ai bien compté en une
année quatre doses bruno mais germann
quand même ça remet pas un petit peu en
question l'efficacité des vaccins quand
on sait en plus qu'on va avoir une
nouvelle version en mars et un nouveau
variant avec l'efficacité qu'on connaît
alors tout d'abord juste mais je me
permets de faire une petite correction
de ce que je viens d'entendre donc le
vaccin actuellement à base d'arn
messager n'est pas du tout une thérapie
génique ça n'est pas du tout un vaccin
expérimental c'est un vaccin qui a suivi
toutes les démarches nécessaires pour
obtenir l'autorisation sur le marché est
aujourd'hui plus de 7 milliards
d'individus sur la planète ont reçu
cette vaccination
donc jamais un médicament a bénéficié
d'autant de personnes sur un court
content aussi court pour pouvoir en
déterminer et l'efficacité et les effets
secondaires potentiels alors je suis
d'accord effectivement il peut y avoir
nécessité d'adapter le vaccin mais comme
vous le savez ceux ci prend au minimum
une centaine de jours or entre autant
aujourd'hui notamment nous faisons face
invariante delpas et malheureusement il
y à une baisse de la protection conférée
par la double dose donc attendre une
possible adaptation du
delà de la dose de rappel aux variants
omicron il devrait arriver dans les
semaines qui viennent serait totalement
on va dire
malheureusement
erronée car ça permettrait d'exposer la
personne à un risque important de faire
une forme grave lié au delta et de se
retrouver à l'hôpital ou en réanimation
il sera toujours temps si nécessaire par
la suite de recevoir une dose adapté
mais pour le moment la dose de rappel
permet de booster l'immunité d'obtenir
une protection parfaite contre la souche
qui circulent quasiment à 100%
aujourd'hui sur le territoire national
et donc c'est ce qu'il faut faire il
faut suivre les recommandations des
autorités sanitaires
on verra par la suite ce qu'il en sera
pour le variantes ou mikron aujourd'hui
à nouveau on ne sait même pas quelle en
est sa virulence on sait à peu près que
la triple vaccination devrait conférer
un certain niveau de protection certes
diminué mais néanmoins 70% de protection
ça reste une protection parfaitement
acceptable même les vaccins contre la
grippe ne peut confère pas une telle
protection aujourd'hui alors sauf que ça
met pas en confiance tout le monde amène
à 60,18 regarder ce message télégramme
un qui nous parvient on aimerait en voir
à la fin de ce qu vite car la
multiplication des doses de rappel le
met pas en confiance c'était à la
question suivante est-ce que 2022 ce
sera mieux donc cette personne qui ne se
sent pas vraiment en confiance avec
toutes ces dose de rappel jouer le
mélange justement je rebondis sur ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure ses
traitements alternatifs la fase heures
sur une pilule qui sort aux etats-unis
aujourd'hui
efficace à 90% contre les formes graves
pourquoi ne pas attendre que cette
pilule soit produite en masse à ce que
en tout cas c'est la question que
beaucoup se posent vous votre avis
eh bien écoutez cette pilule j'ai suivi
comme tout le monde que se réactive sur
les formes graves mais le problème est
plutôt de
se demander pourquoi depuis le 1er
janvier 2020 cela va faire deux ans
d'efforts européens et des fonds
nationaux en robe ont été développés
pour pouvoir évaluer des molécules
inconnu certes mais aussi des molécules
de ceux connus et qu' il ya eu de
nombreux laboratoires d'université qui
ont eu des sommes très importantes pour
aller évaluer et on le sait d'ailleurs
souvent ce sont des anciennes molécules
à peine modifiée qui peuvent servir il y
a bien entendu la prévention at on des
médicaments pour la prévention attendre
les médicaments pour la phase passe de
contact est-ce qu'on a des médicaments
pour l'homme le moment où on est positif
mais asymptomatiques ou que
symptomatique et il semblerait tournée
des possibilités sur les formes peu
graves dès l'instant qu'on est en milieu
hospitalier ou voir même plus il y as
probablement alors ça a été le débat on
le sait bien sûr l'accord anti douleur
mais qui ne fait grec tonnes tous ces
produits qu'on a évoqué il n'est pas
sortie d'études on n'a pas permis qu'ils
sortaient des reculs importants c'est ça
qui est tout à fait de marche il y a eu
des études européenne qui n'ont pas
abouti laissons au moins dire écrire
dire très clairement aux scientifiques
dans des cadres habituels
d'expérimentation que ça ne marche pas
qu'on la laisse pas croire qu'on peut
faire marcher en attendant on aurait dû
depuis deux ans avoir des molécules
alternatif sur le marché j'entends bien
que c'est toujours longue mais pour ce
qui est comme disait monsieur mes
regards ban pour les rênes mais sachez
qu'on connaissait depuis très longtemps
c'est pas le problème c'est pas une
expérimentation de sauf que les uns et
les autres pandémies non ont été
apportés donc on n'a pas eu le value
utilisé il y à une nécessité mettre sur
le marché des molécules qui doivent
exister ou qui doivent être déjà en
phase iii que l'on doit pouvoir mettre
sur le marché c'est une attente une
jambe bien évidemment fanqua très bas
face à cette proposition vous vous
partagez cette demande et cette urgence
de voeux nombreux français tout de même
écouté que vous dire vous savez c'est un
cessez le bilan coût avantage cheyrou
juriste c'est à dire que évidemment il
ya des risques à se faire vacciner mais
il ya demain sans doute moins que de
base être vaccinés et et voilà il faut
parer au plus pressé et un jour le
traitement arrivera et puis aussi on
sait que tout pandémie fini par
s'arrêter la grippe espagnole s'est
arrêtée tout seul
mais ce qu'il faut c'est tenir jusqu'à
ce que cela s'arrête en ayant le moins
de morts possibles donc pare au plus
pressé et puis individuellement soyons
responsables dans votre comportement
personnel emmanuel macron l'instant qui
nous dit qu il est probable encore
justement vers des rappels réguliers ça
va pas vraiment arrangé beaucoup de
monde certainement l'hypothèse d'une
obligation vaccinale et existe dit
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron bruno
m'égare ban
le président qui évoque aussi la
vaccination des 11 5 ans il dit que
c'est souhaitable mais que ça sera
laissée à la discrétion des départs en
votre réaction justement on en a
beaucoup débattu ensemble évidemment
l'hypothèse d'une obligation vaccinale
existe ça veut dire ça y est on prépare
clairement le terrain et et c'est
souhaitable selon le médecin en tout cas
que vous êtes
alors comme vous l'avez dit les
coronavirus ce sont des virus à
l'origine d'infections peu immunisante
il était donc attendu
qu'il serait difficile de mettre au
point un vaccin qui conférerait une
immunité prolonger deux fait
effectivement on s'attendait à voir des
rappels avec une certaine fréquence que
l'on va découvrir au fur et à mesure
bien sûr du temps et de l'arrivée de
variants nouveau cela ne me choque pas
il y à beaucoup d'autres vaccinations
pour lequel il ya plusieurs dose de
rappel à faire face à ce que le tétanos
est destiné dit non au montage par
contre pour les six mois
il n'est pas encore dit qu'il faille
faire des rappels tous les six mois le
tétanos vous faites la vaccination à la
naissance puis en appel à six mois puis
un an puis à 5 ans puis tous les dix ans
voyez donc c'est quelque chose
d'habituel
c'est pas renoncer pas tous les six mois
on verra on verra a personne aujourd'hui
ne peut dire c'est un sujet est en
déficit immunitaire qu'il faille faire
une dose de rappel dans six mois on ne
sait pas par contre très probablement
nous faudra adapter le vaccin ou les
dose de rappel à venir aux souches
prédominante qui vont arriver et avec le
temps il faut rester confiant des
vaccins plus puissants
induisant une immunité plus solides
seront développés donc pour revenir au
sujet de la vaccination des enfants
comme vous le savez je suis plutôt
favorable
bien sûr sans obligation il n'y a aucune
raison de maintenir dans la population
un groupe de personnes non vaccinées qui
d'abord s'exposerait un risque malgré
tout de formes graves de la maladie il
faut rappeler qu'il ya une quinzaine
d'enfants décédés en france de kobe de
19 et environ 5000 hospitalisé y compris
en réanimation donc dispose d'un moyen
parfaitement efficace pour réduire la
morbi mortalité y compris chez les
enfants il faut leur faire profiter sans
compter évidemment que le fait de
réduire la circulation du virus dans la
population
réduire et le risque
d'exposer des personnes plus âgées nées
à risque de faire des formes graves de
la maladie tant à la vaccination
obligatoire je pense malheureusement
elle sera compliqué à mettre dans les
faits est donc très clairement elle
deviendra obligatoire lorsque l'on
pourra trouver et démontrer la
vaccination des nouveau-nés sera sans
danger à ce moment là il sera généralisé
merci en tout cas à tous les 3 france 5
à 3 baffes joëlle mélin et bruno megaman
d'avoir été avec nous et c'est la fin